the day starts at 4:00 a.m. for these
fishermen as they return to town to sell
what they've caught conversation
revolves around the election and who
they'll trust to lead Indonesia for some
it's Ganer pranoo a former governor
who's promised to improve access to
higher
education I will vote for Gano prano
he's skinny but he is a good man it's
okay that I'm uneducated but I want my
children to go to
school for others it's the defense
minister prau
he's pledged to continue the current
government's development
policies has promised to improve the
lives of farmers and fishermen easn
usara province is one of the poorest in
the country and living conditions
influence how many Indonesians will vote
I want the next leader to pay more
attention to us and reach out to the
poor people voters living in poverty in
both Urban and remote rural areas make
up a significant demographic although
Indonesia has made progress in poverty
alleviation according to government data
at least 25 million people live below
the poverty line that means they survive
on less than $36 a month in addition
about 30% of the population is
considered economically insecure meaning
they would struggle to make ends meet if
they fell ill or were affected by a
natural
disaster if we talk about data it's like
the iceberg phenomena and in fact the
number of poor people in Indonesia is
more than
stated at a rally in the capital
supporters of Anis baseden a former
academic who until recently was the
governor of Jakarta said they believe
Indonesia's economic growth has left
them
behind Mr Al really cares about us and
he also visits those poor people
often back in Flores Austina isn't sure
who to vote for her income as a small
scale farmer is just over $400 a
year our hope is that after the election
please consider us Ordinary People
because we still need basic things like
water roads electricity successive
elections have brought no change to her
community she says so she's looking for
a president who will improve the lives
and the future of her children Jessica
Washington aler M
Indonesia make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer